what's up guys welcome back to episode 2
of my 3d Java game development tutorials
this is exactly where we left off I
haven't changed anything
we're just well where we are ready to
keep on working on this on this epic
game first thing I want to do is say
that where you need to do some really
important things today - what were the
most important things early on early on
in development and the first thing is we
need to talk about threads so first
thing I want to do is create a thread
okay
so I'll explain this code right now
actually private is the visibility
modifier basically private says that
only this class can can use threads okay
only display it or Java can use this
public means that anything in the whole
freaking world can use it um you can see
it basically so private means that you
only just play logic I we can say that
thread is basically the way to explain
freighters it's it enables you to do
multiple tasks simultaneously so you
know at the same time which as you can
imagine really important for games cuz
we we want to be able to render multiple
things at once all that all that good
stuff I'm not gonna go too far into it
and yeah as you know in Java to create a
thread to read an object we need a grid
okay hang on to use it we need to create
an object and we have to give that
object name so I just called thread
because that's easy to remember and the
other thing I wanna create is a boolean
again private and a boolean is something
that's true or false okay two possible
values true or false and I'm going to
call it running and I want to set it to
false because it's not running at the
moment our game isn't running at the
moment not yet that is
yeah so the next thing we need to do is
we need to actually initialize this
thread and the way we do that is I'm
going to create a a method called start
and in that method I'm going to just
simply check for something really quick
I want to go if running return and this
might be a bit difficult to understand
so let's play it
this is sort of the way that I want to
do this tutorials I don't want to add
too much code at once I'd rather have
shorter videos where I add you know like
10 20 lines of code but I explain
everything for all of you guys who don't
understand what this means
you know I'll explain it for you guys so
that you can understand what it means
because that's sort of that's the point
of it of a tutorial if you want a copy
code from someone just you know go just
that download like an open-source game
or something which you know tap down
download the source code to that and you
will be fine so yeah so basically this
is an if statement and it's basically
saying if running equals true then
return
now what return means is it's going to
exit out of the met out of the method
because the reason that we type this
code is because think about this if it's
already running so if running equals
true we don't want to initialize the
game again because it's already running
so you know that but if it's not running
then don't return in other words don't
get out of this method keep doing
whatever's below it by the way if you
hit ctrl shift F on your cable that's
gonna format you code so in other words
if you're going like 600 plus 23 I don't
know divided by 6 times 8 yeah coach
wall strips F and it'll set it out
really nicely
so yeah that's control shift F we could
put this into curly braces I usually
like putting if statements and curly
braces braces but you don't need to and
because it's one word return kind of
looks nicer if you don't so yeah okay so
if it's in other words if it's not
running then set running to equal true
because we want it to start running and
the most important thing probably is to
actually initialize the thread and the
way we do this is we go thread equals
new thread with this and again it's
undefined because we need to implements
runnable
and yeah no more iris is giving us an
arrow here because you know we need to
we actually need to run we actually have
to make a method here called run public
avoid run and there we go nowhere is yay
okay so that's pretty simple and the
other thing what you want to do is
actually start the thread so that's how
we initialize a thread and they'll think
that I the other thing that I want to
add at this point is actually a stop
method as well this isn't really
necessary but because I want this to add
to run in as an applet later um and
basically what an applet is it's it
enables this to be one inside a web
browser so the the I reckon the most
popular example is if you think about
Minecraft if you had a microphone air
you can actually play the game inside
the web browser so that's because it's
an applet so I you know it's always good
to be able to do that in the future so
that's what I want to do right now so
I'm making a stop method so this is
basically the reverse of the start
method the explanation mark means not so
if it's not running then don't worry
about this map but get out of this
method if it's not running because it's
not running then we already for
we've already fulfilled our duty so if
it's not running then set running sorry
if it if it is running and we want to
stop it there's that running take off
false and thread dot join and we
actually need a when you actually need
to try to that you can see that it says
you miss around with try and catch I'm
just going to type it out so try to join
this thread and if that fails and simply
catch an exception and this is just
normal Java syntax and then we want to
exit obviously yeah so that's pretty
much that's our start and stop method
how much time are we up six minutes
brilliant quickly explain this so it's
going to try and join and join is it's
gonna waste it's gonna weigh for the
thread to die so it's gonna try and end
the thread if that does not work and
then it's going
an exception and again we're creating
the exception object we've called is-8
what it's gonna do is it's gonna print
interact a stack trace which is really
hard to explain and that is gonna
actually exit the program so yeah that's
how start and stop thing and finally I
also want to create the main game loop
game loop so how we gonna do is we'll
make a while loop so while it while
running equals true do whatever there
and we'll we'll talk about that next
time the other thing I want to talk
about is actually um I really like to
check if this code is currently
operational in other words if it's
working because if I if I code for an
hour and then I go back and then I'm
like hang on this isn't this doesn't
even work you know and obviously it's
not gonna it's not gonna throw us an
error because the syntax is correct
so say if we had an error like that so
if it's not running blah blah blah then
if we run it you know what I'm gonna say
the difference it's running it's fun
running us here by the way so the way we
are the way that I like to check it is
simply by going this oh hang on I should
probably actually initialize that method
so as you can see we're not actually
using a stop yet we'll do that later
when we go into applet yeah so if it's
if it's okay so what this code does is
the same game this is the good thing
about Eclipse as well if you hit your
arm if you put the the type II thingy on
a word it's going to highlight all the
words of the same name so we can say
that game is the object of this display
class so it's gosh it's cause it's gonna
search this class for the method called
start which is right here and it's going
to obviously you know run that method so
that's really important and what we need
to do is we need a to check the code
best way to do it is just print print a
line and
[Music]
I don't know working working and what
that's going to do is if we run it as
you can see I've made an error here on
purpose we'd be like hmm it's running
but it's not working why is that then
you go back and you're like oh right of
course
I put this here run it and tada yeah
it's working so that's that's sort of
like a way to test that we don't know
the website don't need this but yeah so
that's that's the way I like to do it um
and that's probably the end for this
tutorial next time I think we get
started on some graphic stuff I'm not
sure yeah we're probably will so make
sure you watch the next tutorial which
will come out tomorrow tomorrow I want
to try and make one of these every day
and yeah so tomorrow we're gonna try and
let me just film at this tomorrow we're
gonna try and implement some graphics
things maybe actually draw some pixels
to the screen so that'll be exciting and
yeah that's it so I'll see you guys
later bye
[Music]